hello and welcome to weekend review with
me Jane CEQA Kevin Maguire and Andrew
Pierce are here to look back through the
bigger stories of the past seven days
before we get started let's get a taste
of what the week was all about could
austerity be over far left syriza won
power and Greece promising an ease to
the financial squeeze in the country
George Osborne insisted the UK's
economic recovery is on track GDP growth
slowed to 0.5 percent in the final
quarter of last year but with less than
a hundred days to go the party leaders
embarks on a war of words ahead of the
general election as polls forecast two
hung parliament the Reverend Libby Lane
became the Church of England's first
female bishop against the vocal position
of son Apple recorded the biggest
quarterly profits for a public company
ever making 18 billion dollars in three
months Vladimir Putin was called a
common criminal dressed as a head of
state by the widow of Alexander
Litvinenko is an inquiry began into his
death
New York shut down for Snowmageddon in
the end though it was more of a light
dusting than a whiteout the TV station
in the Netherlands went off air after a
man armed with a fake gun entered the
building and demanded to be put on air
and world leaders joined Holocaust
survivors marking 70 years since Soviet
troops liberated the Auschwitz death
camp I don't if you so much of the
coverage of Auschwitz but extraordinary
moving footage of people returning some
lot of them for the first time and
probably the last time now absolutely
you watch those survivors and it is one
of the great crime scenes of history and
you watch them and you cannot imagine
what they endured at the time but you
also in the back of your mind as the
knowledge that ten years time the ranks
will be thinner so it's better we should
we should honor them now
never forget this should great courage
din then return they did and if you
haven't been to outfits people it should
almost be part of your education with
school children should be made to go and
see just how terribly it really was
indeed well let's move on to the stories
throughout the week and the first story
they've picked out for us is the rise of
the far left in Greece and after years
of spending cuts imposed as part of the
country's financial bailout from the EU
this
is a party campaigning on a promise to
end austerity has taken power our Europe
correspondent Robert Nesbit reports it's
an event heavy with symbolism the moment
a new leader is given the mandate by the
Greek president but Alexis tsipras again
as chewing a tie is not a man given to
formality his message here I'm in a
hurry to govern let's get on with it
when it came to the oath there was
another telling change to convention the
atheist asked the Orthodox Church to
stay out of the ceremony his oath was
civil and to the point
mr. president I assure you upon my honor
that I will observe the Constitution and
the laws and serve the general interest
of the Greek nation voters in
monastiraki hope the new government will
make their day-to-day lives a little
easier as the one they want to go out
have coffee have a chat have a job
there's an enormous weight of
expectation now on mr. tsipras to
improve the lot of his citizens and
secure less onerous conditions attached
to the loans keeping Greece afloat for
this young leader overturning a 40-year
stranglehold on Greek politics by the
center left and center right may have
been the easy part
so is an austerity that's failed or is
it the eurozone euro zone is a disaster
and Greece should never have been in the
single currency because the economy
isn't strong enough or big enough they
cook the books and the Germans and the
French went along with it because of
this vainglorious project having 19
countries in this ludicrous straitjacket
and and I think the I suspect that the
the series of project will fail too
because I do not think that man will be
able to deliver what Greeks want which
is not to pay they made these promises
to EU why why shouldn't they do
absolutely not calling for the be
cancelled they're calling for them to be
rescheduled so you can draw the economy
I think if I lived in Greece I'd
probably because he was
cereza to end to end austerity if you
had the economic misery they're enduring
in Britain it'd be eight million people
unemployed now in the in the Euro there
is a structural problem with the euro
that you can't when your economy goes in
the
can't devalue your currency big in the
old days it would have devalued the the
drachma if you're going to do that
you're gonna have big fiscal transfers
around the area you'd have to put money
into Greece but you don't put it you
don't put it in and then impose
austerity which is putting people out of
work you're gonna grow an economy by
putting people out of work or make an
important to be in work and paying and
he recognizes that look you might get a
cheaper gin and tonic next time you go
so you'll probably be happy but I think
I think they give people around Europe
hope by challenging austerity rise on
the left here in the UK for inspiration
no I think absolutely reverse will
happen and I think it's amazing when
people like a capable guy talk about
structural problems the structural
problem of the ER is it doesn't work
it is a doomed foolish vainglorious
project that doesn't work you cannot
have a Greek economy operated on the
same level as the German economies like
a Rolls Royce in a car horse I need
support in the car it probably works
rather well for Belgium Luxembourg
Germany and the left will not flourish
here I think actually people will cut
will see the problems in Greece and
think whew what a relief it's quite a
list to return all the loot that their
oligarchs the marbles now first up it's
Benedict Cumberbatch's been described as
a slip of the tongue he's played lots of
characters from a different era but it
seems that his vocabulary might be
decades out of date - he is apologised
after saying he was devastated to have
caused a fence after using the word
coloured on a US TV show to describe
black actors I mean I'm sorry I'm sorry
he feels devastated because I think he's
a great guy he's a good actor and he
meant no racial offense whatsoever when
he used the word colored it's it's not a
word I would use I would call somebody
black but there was no intent to cause
offence and I think it's a storm in a
teacup and in America of course people
are more color sensitive not least this
year because there are no black actors
nominated for an Oscar but that was the
point isn't any what he was saying he
was actually defending black Act doesn't
saying that there isn't the diversity
and in casting particularly in Britain
and that was the irony he was trying to
be helpful and progressive and I agree I
think it's the intent in language
that's that always counts he apologizes
actually inadvertently raised an issue I
don't think that many people criticized
criticizing but but certainly colored is
a very derogatory term but you often
hear in in Britain by an older
generation who don't mix with people who
are black Asian or from other ethnic
minorities yeah do you think it'll
really damaged his no I hope I hope not
but someone did say to me I did tear
some American culture on the road is
saying that's that's his hope of an
Oscar gone okay let's move over to a
second gaffe of the week and this time
it's Boris Johnson the London mayor says
the terrorists are tortured men who are
rejected by women and in desperate need
of self esteem he went a little further
using rather colorful language
describing them in graphic terms
essentially enjoying their own company
whilst watching porn I think self
abusers who may go blind is what he was
getting at all you might mint bankers
actually but nevertheless it rhymes with
that look to be a jihadi you've got to
be a weird and a fanatical and you've
lost your way somehow I think the way he
often just veers off into this this
colorful language I think it's often
shows a kind of its populist appeal but
it just show a lack of judgment too
given that he wants to be a Tory leader
and statement well I think he can be as
abusive about jihad he says he likes and
good luck in there are terrible people
they're misguided and he can call them
that if and it does rhyme with bankers I
completely agree I would call I may be
the case how does it help though it's
not it's not much of an analysis is it
because it then would be nice no it's
not much of an analysis more please
Boris not yes I work out how they end up
going to these disagree stop them
becoming terrorists okay
now the election countdown is of course
continuing and this week marked a
hundred days to go and the party leaders
have certainly set out their stalls for
the campaign's our political editor
Faisal Islam has more hundred days to
make their case get a mandate and
perhaps change a nation's fate the Prime
Minister invited Sky News into the
Cabinet Room today his message as the
eurozone crisis resurfaces don't risk
labor I'm worried about the future of
our country if we end up with a unstable
left-wing government that's
to borrow and spend and wreck the
economic progress that we've made of
course I worry about that but we have a
hundred days to go to make this argument
Ed Miliband's campaigning today not on
the economy but saving the NHS with a
ten-year plan our country's most
precious institution faces I believe its
most perilous moment in a generation and
it is a choice of two futures carrying
on with a conservative plan which has
already led to an NHS in crisis and
threatens the service as we know it or a
Labour plan in the Lib Dem stronghold of
Berman's II Nick Clegg out campaigning
we need to fight and fight very hard in
every street on every doorstep to get
our message across that we want to build
a both stronger economy and a fairer
society and I think we were the only
party that now offers that balance so
with all the major parties facing a
squeeze even the Deputy PM mucking in
it's all hands on deck have you got a
stomach for the next 100 days are you
both feeling ready for the fight well
you know I'm ready for is the TV debates
which the Prime Minister keeps
chickening out if David Cameron's record
was half as good as he pretended he
would be going up against his rivals
instead he's chickening out because he's
got a he's got a record it can't defend
well Kaname growth slowing he's put up
taxes 30 and a half billion he hasn't
cut them deficit he's missed all these
targets this week you saw an NHS crisis
he's mucked up the examine system the
gaps getting bigger come on you know and
now you're not going to come out at the
central office propaganda come on you
can bring it all but you know if we had
a good record he'd be out there except
debate this first week of campaigning
what a complete disaster Fred Miliband
who goes on the NHS and is disowned by
not one health set former Labour health
secretary to John Hutton and Alan
Milburn both completely disowned then
you get Alan Johnson who was also held
separately not sure about this strategy
so three labour health sectors are all
completely so right to focus on the
economy and I'll never write the folks
on the NHS I think you've got to do them
both but the NHS is labour stronger hand
the economy obviously the Tories were
leading in the polls but Alan Milburn
you normally slag him off the normal
form of labour
he'll segregate and let's face it he's
making a killing an absolute killing out
of private medical care taking NHS car
that should have been Blair when he did
why then Milburn has got a vested
self-interest well anyway whatever kevin
says to very senior former labour
hurting them whatever lately refuses
Labour's entire campaign strategy but
not your peril she said that this is
gonna be the nastiest election he thinks
in a long time that they've got these
big election strategies to come across
from the states and it's really gonna
become quite big the Tories did that
rather disgraceful Shin Fein posing good
when when they approached in feign to
see if they'd be taking the seats as did
the Lib Dems I did the SNP as did labour
because you're doing your calculations
but every election campaign is always
said it's gonna be the nastiest um I'm
very very now the ninety-two was
particularly delighted
oh it's disgraceful they tampered with
the pic the picture of Ed Miliband they
hadn't yes it really did look like that
we're admitted that we're okay tampering
with pictures of Ed Miliband right
you're wrong in a quiz for you guys now
what links these four things we've got
Nutella Robocop sama bin Laden and Tom
Cruise they're thinking find out after
the break
welcome back to week in review with me
Jane circuit Kevin Maguire associate
editor of The Daily Mirror and Andrew
pierce consultant editor of The Daily
Mail join me before the break we asked
what links these items you're a good
guess I wonder have all been accepted in
North Korea in some way in videos or
whatever you've probably name-drop the
lot I'm here it is to do with names they
didn't get them these are all baby names
that have been banned around the world
a judge in France this week told a
couple that they couldn't call their
child Nutella because it's the trade
name of a spread we've also a we've got
a list of other names that have been
banned you'll be glad we've chosen the
pictures that we did Lucifer was banned
in New Zealand girl anus was banned in
Denmark Osama bin Laden was banned as a
name in Turkey Tom banned in Portugal
was a nickname and you have to use a
full name Midwife inside and scrotum
were also banned in Mexico to call their
child screw somebody I know you get
called that but I have to tell people
when they shout that out you it's not
your real name and a midwife in South
Way also don't want you had a patient
who wanted to call her daughter
chlamydia lovely nice it's not it's not
a flower right let's move on to the rau
over the death penalty bit of a
handbrake turn in Oklahoma in the United
States that last year there was an
outcry when problems administering a
lethal cocktail led to a prison arriving
and paying for 43 minutes before he died
of a heart attack
well it's raised further questions about
capital punishment in the country in
words has more relatives and friends of
a condemned man come to say what could
be their final goodbyes he's due to be
executed the following day and as they
gather there's still no word of a
reprieve shortly afterwards Richard
Glossip got his stay of execution it may
buy him a few more months but his life
is unlikely to be spared even though he
didn't kill anyone
he was accused of pain an accomplice to
murder the owner of a motel where they
worked
the actual killer was offered a plea
deal and he escaped the death penalty in
return for testifying against Glossop
Oklahoma has been under the
international spotlight ever since the
botched execution of convicted killer
Clayton Lockett last year the prison
warren called it a bloody mess problems
administering the lethal injection meant
that Lockett was left writhing in pain
for 43 minutes before finally dying of a
heart attack even though a new death
chamber has been built inside this
prison there's still a fierce debate
about the effectiveness of one of the
drugs used in the lethal injection
cocktail but the death penalty retains
public support in the state and some
lawmakers aren't too fussed at how it's
done and if it got to a point where we
didn't have the technological
advancements to have lethal injections
and I would support hanging or beheading
or whatever it would take to make sure
that that person in the end meets his
justice what do you think about the fact
that America goes out there on the world
stage it criticizes countries where they
flogged and they behead people but it it
still puts you despair don't you it's a
leader of the free world and the death
penalty is barbaric and horrible and
it's it's an anachronism but it's the
law in that country so I suppose they
should just get on and do it and also
people in this country who call for it
to be brought back when do we see
horrific crimes every time somebody is
in prison for murdering a child yeah
there are calls I understand that
impulse if it's your child somebody you
know you understand that but you got to
have a law that Petare protects us all
and I'm reminded really that Gandhi
saying about when he was asked would be
Western you know what anything about
Western civilization he said it would be
a good thing and it is but the barbaric
and America is one of the worst culprits
here right let's move on to your paper
stories of the week air Kevin you first
and this is an unwelcome cold caller who
got through to David camera and he
wasn't trying to sell life insurance or
PPI he was apparently off his face on
booze and cocaine 11 o'clock in the
morning right so I could some day clean
some cabinet ministers and earlier
careers actually believe what we're told
but it kind of well it's embarrassing I
think rather than a major security
breach but I do wonder how often it
happened before because he seems so
relaxed about it Cameron
you know we live in a society which is
relatively open and that is a good thing
you ring up the number-10 switchboard
and you claim to be somebody what
they're supposed to do bring you back
every time what happens in an emergency
then you're gonna waste time because he
was posing as the head of GCHQ you would
have thought GCHQ being the spice and
would have an elaborate series of code
words and but clearly but they gave out
they gave out Richard Hannigan's mo
Banda is a most extraordinary you I
think the key bit is you would have
thought would have thought I like the
fact that this guy got through and then
when they said oh it's a hoax call he
not very good good good Tales it was so
bad he should be recruited by mi5 or am
i season a diem disc jockey got through
to the Queen pretend he was the Canadian
Prime Minister she fell for it
completely in response to that stick you
still go to the Daily Mail pretending to
be a journalist onto your next story and
you've chosen a story about immigration
and the Prime Minister it's lined up
Kevin ill no regrette rien yeah this
will be part of the election campaign
and why shouldn't it because immigration
is a huge problem it's such a huge
problem that the labor leader of the
Opposition admitted meant let's not
forget forgot to mention it in his
conference speech last year son of
migrants and Cameron is making the point
that actually it would be better if
there were few because there'd be more
jobs for British people there'd be
better social occasion because there are
problems with multiculturalism that the
failure to integrate properly in
communities has he succeeded in getting
those numbers down that's about it
matter what it need last manifesto he
said he'd get it down at tens of
thousands under a hundred thousand I've
lasted over than two hundred and sixty
three thousand a year now
hi Otto hi Anthony inherit from my bit
faster side complete record of failure
which really you left out until Jane
came a bar to run to one of you let's
get immigration it down people who've
come labor labor would increase it
people have come to Britain
work hard they pay more in taxes and
they take out in service 163,000 from
the EU are on job seekers allowance no
that's been made it's been reported
that's come recorded where
it's an official statistic it's not I
figure it's about 40,000 oh and so those
are in between jobs role figures of
different kind apple the company's mega
profit server picked all others in
history they made 18 billion dollars
last quarter it's astonishing numbers
yeah 12 billion 12 billion pounds mainly
from sales of the I thought it's
fantastically successful I use its its
computers and the phone my myself I wish
they'd just put didn't put so much
effort into into dodging taxes and that
is my beef with this sort of vampire
squid that if it makes money in Brittany
she'll pay taxes in Britain and it's
rather like Google great service they
should pay their taxes Starbucks should
pay their taxes and they started Amazon
should pay their taxes and yeah you can
applaud Apple in so many ways but not
the tax dodging it has because their
products do something in a way that a
lot of other technology doesn't it
connects its intuitive a relationship
with Apple products than any other I
worship my Apple Mac computer at home
and because she would approve of it in a
gilt frame exactly it she would approve
the course of a great commercial success
at Apple but they are fantastic
computers and the iPhones are phenomena
to who bothers with a blackberry now
they were the rage once and they're
completely well they're past it remember
Microsoft ruled the world
IBM ruled the world Apple could go but
they have they survived the loss of
Steve Jobs incredibly well right so onto
your people or things of the week and
that Kevin was starting with you and
you've chosen
Kim Sears she's going up this week why
she is Kim X but you know there we are
Andy Murray's wife to be watching him
playing tennis and she used some pretty
pretty forceful industrial language but
I like the passion and she wasn't
shouting it out you had to get lip
readers looking at film to actually get
it and now you don't like a hobby and so
you probably don't like her but good for
her we wouldn't have had an eyelid if it
was a bloke I think good fair play to
her I still can't stand idly Mary but
good luck to her I feel sorry for I feel
you know she goes long supportive and to
have people lip-reading
his wife got into the same trouble last
year remember during the Davis couple
some context she she to use rather
earthy language got pretty good dose
opposed to hers appala dear
so she you're sending her up you like
the the customer gym and the color of
her language but who are you sending
down we're sending to subtitlers yeah
and TV because off comer said it so
often get it wrong instead of said
giving to our toddlers it says give to
ayatollahs now I know some toddlers can
be ayatollahs and come from yeah it's
roll their house but I think they have
to clean it up when you are on I mean
live subtitling programs about this I
suppose and but it for pre-recorded
films and things it's a lot easier to do
it in advance but it is apparently a
problem with the voice recognition
software goodness knows what you know if
you're watching this subtitles I do
oppositing that down who are you sending
up Andrew your first one up this is this
I'm a great cat lover only last night I
was doing a fundraiser for the cat
protection organization about thousands
of pounds very large check got submit
this attack at his tax was buried the
owner thought he died in a car crash
they only got a neighbor or friends had
buried the cat the cat he hadn't died at
all and like Lazarus came back from the
dead happy later came back a bit of a
state but good on him well done well did
bark at but going down a bit older he
didn't survive defeated I'd Mississippi
the dinosaur in the British Museum he's
been there since 1979 being moved to a
different part of the museum the word is
the staff call that dinosaur Edie
Miliband oh he's been practicing about a
week yeah says Pierre Soros all right so
let's send him down there we go thank
you for joining us for our review of the
week don't forget that you can catch
Kevin and Andrew in action on the Sky
News press preview along with all other
paper reviewers as they take a look at
the days at newspapers every evening
10:30 and 11:30 on Sky News will be back
for much more next week so for now it's
goodbye from them goodbye and it's
goodbye from me goodbye